chapter nine inside I can things eleven
chapters check this one real quick check
it some soil you know I know p-people
beep-beep
so I was like [ __ ] with this
now
the budget [ __ ] everywhere huh what sky
Holdings I'm green it's a green keycard
never far a level for this is red it's
just green
[Music]
this is that computer
instant camera what the [ __ ]
[Music]
Hey
exact
okay [ __ ] camera that cheese
[ __ ] this Dale
tanzir monitor what's in here lap cat
when down clumps take pictures corpse
card writer
a green card the [ __ ] has gone on here
hey barks I'm [ __ ] it out these are
the people I think that went to they
went to the future hey Matt take it back
there if I could for an eye scanner
right there's this batch Frank Frank Oh
see you there
let's get the crap out of me I can't
believe you're here
they told me you quit got to go upstairs
and everything all right yeah well you
know me I'm a career opportunity guys so
[ __ ] see total management gave me your
job well sort of the same
responsibilities at least and well my
own so it's all right well good on you
Joe best of luck now if your looks good
they said you already left did you
forget something
no yeah I forgot something listen I'm a
little tight on time here I said one
evil mustache work here you even doing
down here
well like I said I was given your job
so a fry ride was still this part of the
labs is actually off-limits oh you
probably shouldn't be here look see
don't you know right I know
hey can we grab a beer down it beer oh
great
what the [ __ ]
right sound unlocked
now this one's unlocked
can I get this guy out here check the
future real quick and make sure nothing
in here I don't need
nothing in yet there you are why the
hell haven't you done anything about
that leak yet effects that the leak
hello anyone home the leak next door
numbnuts do you have any I wait look I'm
sorry I could catch is vending machine
if I could have something from the
vending machine
don't you think I would have sorry I
diet it's in all fruit diets the miss
tell you what you find me some fruit
I'll find you and make sure that sorry
pepra here's your Apple what is that
is this some kind of joke what's the
matter with you
I'm
photographs
death pan
[ __ ] is that a woman seven break okay
[ __ ] on that
what
oh I should put the Apple in there and
see a whole mold or something you know
camp at me
oh if I'd swing in I know where I can
get some soil and I know what to pick it
up with
I tuned Fras this stick is Doug guess
suck a dick soil okay it's happening
again
all right dad great
at the find out what happened
something happen here Luke
put some dirt on it
meanwhile what this means that from now
on you will be in charge of not only
yours but Frank's assignments - that's
right
that means downstairs lab sanitation
drain assignments the works that's gone
on Joe
I thank you sorry what about Frank what
the hell is that
oh that's what happened that has
happened at the same time I was like
flashback Wow nice hell up salami a good
salami never fails
it better be clever actually
I'm so clever and you brought me an
apple
good there's no eating in the lab so
I'll just pop out for a few to get some
fresh air
give me this
I just dumped this on the computer and
just F it up hey just have it up
oh [ __ ]
I hope he doesn't I wouldn't run into
myself then I might run into myself
right now
go [ __ ] yourself
should should I be writing this down I
don't have anything to write with shut
up and pay attention you are standing on
the brink wrap
oh [ __ ] get the [ __ ] in there get the
[ __ ] in there
[ __ ] you computer [ __ ] you
[Music]
poor dr. Lambert keep your voice tough
guys Shh yep I faked faked what you
detailed this exact scenario to me 14 oh
yeah of course you do do you it was a
mere day ago the earlier version of you
had to see me die and get dragged off
and yet I had to survive long enough to
assist you in carrying out your mission
so I staged my premature demise
hey you're not dying
I am dying all right despite my better
judgment I attempted to circumvent
getting shots by taking a different
route to the labs than originally
planned I foolishly believed I might
actually bend the rules of cause and
effect gaping hole in my gut dr. Lambert
I no more questions did you destroy the
research station like I asked hey the
computer thank God now there is just one
last matter to attend to
I need you to the device you see that
console behind you check the numbers in
the okay
Trek four to nine for nine six seven to
nine five I'm sure dear God I have
configured the device yeah [ __ ] Frank
isn't it one last thing you can never
return dr. Lambert are you [ __ ] that
yeah what do you think's in here